Speaking of Psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning one of our favorite episodes from the past. In July 2021, I talked to psychologist Julia Simner about how people with synesthesia experience the world and what we can learn from studying this fascinating condition. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology, we'll be back with new episodes in a couple of weeks. Thank you for listening. Words that taste like orange candy, music that projects brilliant, shimmering colors, numbers that come with personalities and full life stories. These are all forms of synesthesia, a neurological condition in which senses such as taste, touch, smell, and vision, link or merge.
《心理学聊聊吧》节目正在放暑假，因此我们重播了一期过去广受欢迎的节目。在2021年7月，我采访了心理学家朱莉娅·西姆纳，探讨了联觉者是如何体验世界的，以及我们能从研究这一迷人病症中学到什么。希望大家喜欢这期来自资料库的节目。《心理学聊聊吧》将在几周内携新节目回归。感谢收听。尝起来像橙子糖的味道、能投射出灿烂闪烁色彩的音乐、带有性格和完整人生故事的数字。这些都是联觉的形式，这是一种神经系统疾病，味觉、触觉、嗅觉和视觉等感官在此相互连接或融合。
Historical accounts of people with synesthesia date back hundreds of years, but it's only in recent decades that scientists have been able to use brain imaging, and other modern research methods to gain a better understanding of how synesthesia works and why it might occur. So what does it like to have synesthesia? What might cause it, and how do the brains of people with synesthesia differ from those of people without it? What can we learn about the human mind more generally from studying synesthesia and other sensory differences? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science. and everyday life. Our guest today is Dr. Jules Simner, a professor of neuropsychology at the University of Sussex
关于联觉者的历史记载可以追溯到数百年前，但直到最近几十年，科学家们才能够利用脑成像和其他现代研究方法，更好地理解联觉是如何运作的以及它为什么会发生。那么，拥有联觉是一种什么样的体验？是什么原因导致的？联觉者的的大脑与没有联觉的人有什么不同？通过研究联觉和其他感官差异，我们能对人类心灵有怎样的普遍了解？欢迎收听《心理学聊聊吧》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我们今天的嘉宾是英国萨塞克斯大学的神经心理学教授朱尔斯·西姆纳博士
in the United Kingdom, who specializes in multisensory research. She has studied synesthesia in adults and children for nearly two decades. She also researches other sensory differences, including misophonia, an extreme aversion to certain sounds, and Afantasia, the inability to see pictures in your mind's eye. We'll discuss these today too and talk about what links to things. these threads of research together. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Simner. Thanks very much for the invitation. Some of our listeners have probably heard of synesthesia, or at least the most common forms of it, like people seeing colors when they hear music. But synesthesia is a lot
她专注于多感官研究。近二十年来，她一直在研究成人和儿童的联觉。她还研究其他感官差异，包括恐音症（对某些声音的极端厌恶）以及心盲症（无法在脑海中看到画面的能力）。我们今天也会讨论这些，并探讨这些研究线索之间的联系。感谢您今天做客我们的节目，西姆纳博士。非常感谢您的邀请。我们的一些听众可能听说过联觉，或者至少听说过最常见的一些形式，比如人们听到音乐时会看到颜色。但联觉要比
more varied than people may realize, and you've written and tested for 128 different types. What types are out there? What are the differences and the commonalities? So it's quite hard to estimate exactly how many types of synesthesia there are because some could be quite well hidden, but the ones we know most about are the ones that people can realize most readily and report to us most easily. And I think for that
人们意识到的要多样得多，你已经为128种不同的类型写过文章并做过测试。都有哪些类型？它们之间有什么区别和共同点？因此，很难准确估计到底有多少种联觉，因为有些可能隐藏得很好，但我们最了解的是那些人们最容易意识到并最容易向我们报告的类型。我想正是因为这个原因
reason, we tend to think of the most common types of synesthesia as being the ones that trigger unusual colour perceptions. So experiencing colours when you are reading words, looking at numbers, listening to music,
我们往往认为最常见的联觉类型是那些会触发不寻常颜色知觉的类型。比如你在阅读文字、看数字、听音乐时体验到颜色，
and then perhaps more obscurely swimming, so different swimming strokes, causing different colour perceptions, perhaps even reading Braille also and watching signers in sign language, all of these are known to trigger colours. But as I said, although people talk about colours most often in the context of synesthesia, I think it may be that colours are just the easiest to report because there are many different other synesthetic sensations so you could experience flavours that flood the mouth. So your reading and your mouth is being bombarded with sensations of Yorkshire pudding
然后可能更晦涩一点的是游泳，不同的泳姿会导致不同的颜色知觉，甚至可能包括阅读盲文以及观看手语中的手语者，这些已知都会触发颜色。但正如我所说，尽管人们在联觉的语境下最常谈论颜色，但我认为可能是因为颜色最容易报告，因为还有许多其他不同的联觉感觉。比如你可能会体验到充斥口腔的风味。因此，当你阅读时，你的口腔正受到约克郡布丁、
or processed peas or bitter lemon or nice orange fruit sweets which is what Julia tastes of, my name Julia, or perhaps less pleasant taste. so the taste of earwax or other things that you wouldn't want in your mouth, maybe vomit and so on. So that's also another type of synesthesia we know about. But to answer your question, there are many different kinds of synesthesia. They can trigger colours, taste, smells, textures, bodily feelings, and the compulsion even to put your body into certain shapes or formation.
或是加工豌豆、苦柠檬或是美味的橙子水果糖（朱莉娅就是这个味道，我的名字叫朱莉娅）的感官轰炸，或者也许是不那么令人愉快的味道。比如耳垢的味道或其他你不想放进嘴里的东西，比如呕吐物等等。这也是我们了解的另一种联觉。但为了回答你的问题，联觉有很多不同的种类。它们可以触发颜色、味道、气味、质感、身体感觉，甚至是促使你的身体摆出特定形状或姿势的冲动。
So I remember a very rare case from many years ago of a professor who had an urge to form shapes with his body in response to different words that he heard. So many types. So you said your name has a flavor? Is that universal? How does your name have a flavor? Yeah, that's a good point. So what I described to you, and I think he wouldn't mind me mentioning this at all, what I described to you was the taste of, of the taste of the name Julia as experienced by synestique James Wanerton.
所以我记得多年前有一个非常罕见的病例，一位教授在听到不同的词语时，有一种用身体摆出形状的冲动。有这么多种类。所以你说你的名字有一种味道？这是普遍现象吗？你的名字怎么会有味道？是的，说得好。所以，我向你描述的，我想他不会介意我提起这个，我向你描述的是联觉者詹姆斯·沃内顿所体验到的名字“朱莉娅”的味道。
Now James Wanerton is a particularly special and important synesthette for me. Not only have I studied James for the last 20 years, but James has been an amazing advocate for the synesthesia community. He is the president of the UK Synesthesia Association. And he has taken part in so much outreach himself to help people, to understand the condition. And for James, the name Julia tastes of orange fruit sweets. It's actually a branded fruit sweet.
现在，詹姆斯·沃内顿对我和我来说是一个特别特殊且重要的联觉者。在过去20年里，我不仅研究了詹姆斯，而且詹姆斯一直是联觉社群的杰出倡导者。他是英国联觉协会的主席。他自己参与了大量的公益外展活动，帮助人们理解这种病症。对詹姆斯来说，名字朱莉娅尝起来像橙子水果糖。实际上它是一种带牌子的水果糖。
Yeah, and the interesting thing is most people call me Jules Simna. They use my nickname Jules, but with James, we don't do that because Jules does not taste as nice as Julia. Jules has a bit of an unpleasant taste. James politely tells me it tastes of porridge. I think it may actually taste of grotes. drool or saliva because we know that there are links between the word that trigger synesthesia and the type of taste experienced. And from my 20 years of research, I rather suspect that Jules taste of drool, which is why we
是的，有趣的是，大多数人叫我朱尔斯·西姆纳。他们用我的昵称朱尔斯，但对于詹姆斯，我们不那样做，因为朱尔斯的味道没有朱莉娅那么好。朱尔斯有一种稍微令人不快的味道。詹姆斯礼貌地告诉我它尝起来像粥。我想它实际上可能尝起来像口水或唾液，因为我们已知触发联觉的词语与体验到的味道类型之间存在联系。根据我20年的研究，我相当怀疑朱尔斯尝起来像口水，这就是为什么我们
use the name Julia. So do people with music and color synesthesia actually see colors in the world around them when they hear music? or is it more like just something in their mind's eye? So the answer to that depends on the synestite you're speaking to because there are several different ways that synesthetes can experience their colour. So this was captured quite nicely by our colleagues, Mike Dixon and Daniel Smilick and their team in Canada.
使用朱莉娅这个名字。那么，拥有音乐和颜色联觉的人在听到音乐时，真的能在周围的世界中看到颜色，还是更像是脑海中的某种幻象？所以这个问题的答案取决于你正在与之交谈的联觉者，因为联觉者体验颜色有几种不同的方式。我们的加拿大同事迈克·迪克森、丹尼尔·斯米里克以及他们的团队很好地捕捉到了这一点。
They were able to name projector synesthetes versus associator synesthetes. So associate a synesthetes experience their colours somewhere in the mind's eye like a kind of strong internal mental imagery. Projector synesthetes will see their colours projected out in the outside world. So a couple of examples. If you have coloured letters and numbers and are a projector synestite, you may see those colours superimposed onto the text that you're reading. or if I'm sure he wouldn't mind me describing or as described to me by synesthesia scientist Julian Asher, those colours can be projected out there in the world floating in space.
他们能够将联觉者命名为投影型联觉者与联想型联觉者。联想型联觉者在脑海中的某个地方体验他们的颜色，就像一种强烈内部心理意象。投影型联觉者会看到他们的颜色投影到外部世界中。举几个例子。如果你有带颜色的字母和数字，并且是一个投影型联觉者，你可能会看到这些颜色叠加在你正在阅读的文本上。或者，如果我确信他不会介意我描述的，或者正如联觉科学家朱利安·阿什尔所描述的那样，这些颜色可以被投影到外部世界中，漂浮在太空中。
So Julian Asher is a geneticist who helped us to understand the genetics of synesthesia. And he told me that when he was a young boy, his parents would take him to the symphony and he assumed that the house lights dimmed so that people could see the colours better because for him the orchestra has colours floating above it. He actually thought, why else would anybody dim the house lights apart from to see the synesthetic colours better? That's amazing. So in your mind or in the outside world, yeah.
所以朱利安·阿什尔是一位遗传学家，他帮助我们理解了联觉的遗传学。他告诉我，当他还是个小男孩时，他的父母带他去听交响乐，他以为剧场灯光调暗是为了让人门能更好地看清颜色，因为对他来说，管弦乐队上方漂浮着颜色。他当时甚至在想，除了为了更好地看清联觉色彩之外，还有谁会把剧场灯光调暗呢？这太神奇了。所以是在你的脑海中还是在外部世界中，是的。
And sometimes experience in unusual ways, I remember a student of mine from 20 years ago who experienced pain as colors, and for her, the colors were a cone that projected from her head in color. And if she thought very hard about the shape of the cone, she could moderate the pain of the headache. How common is synesthesia and what's the prevalence in the population? Do we know? Well, yes, so this is something I've spent quite a lot of the last 20 years looking into. our first estimates for commonness were based on asking synesthetes to come forward. So there was a very nice study by Simon Baron Cohen and his colleagues in 1996, and they placed an advert in the newspaper in Cambridge, UK,
有时会以不寻常的方式体验，我记得20年前我的一个学生，她将疼痛体验为颜色，对她来说，这些颜色是一个从她头部以彩色投影出来的圆锥体。如果她非常努力地思考圆锥体的形状，她就可以减轻头痛。联觉有多普遍？它在人群中的患病率是多少？我们知道吗？嗯，是的，这是我过去20年中花了很多时间研究的事情。我们对普遍性的最初估计是基于让联觉者主动站出来。因此，西蒙·巴伦·科恩和他的同事在1996年做了一项非常棒的研究，他们在英国剑桥的报纸上登了一则广告，
and it described synesthesia, and it asked synesthetes to come forward. And he found that the prevalence of synesthesia was one in 2000 from that study. Now, of course, unfortunately, and of course they knew this, they would be radically underestimating because they were relying on synesthetes to buy the newspaper that day, to read the article, to come forward, you know, which are lots of things that filter out people through that process. So in 2000 and in the early 2000s, my colleague Jamie Ward and I decided to, instead of relying on synesthetes to come forward, we started to go out into the general population.
它描述了联觉，并要求联觉者主动站出来。他通过那项研究发现联觉的患病率是两千分之一。现在，当然，不幸的是，而且他们也知道这一点，他们会严重低估，因为他们依靠联觉者在那天买报纸、阅读文章、主动站出来，你知道的，这个过程会过滤掉很多人。所以在2000年和2000年代初，我的同事杰米·沃德和我决定，不再依赖联觉者主动站出来，而是开始走入普通人群。
we would gather large groups of people together and screen every single one of them. And this gave us a sort of better estimate, really, of the prevalence of synesthesia. And since then, I've individually screened almost 20,000 people for synesthesia. And from that, we have quite a good idea that synesthesia is at least 4.4% in the population. So at least one in 23 people have synesthesia. In that study, we were looking at around 140. 40 different types of synesthesia, but we had missed out some quite crucial types. So we also know independently that around 10% of people see time or numbers or letters mapped out in space.
我们会把大量的人聚集在一起，对每一个人进行筛查。这确实为我们提供了关于联觉患病率的一个更好的估计。从那以后，我亲自为近两万人筛查了联觉。由此，我们对联觉在人群中的比例有了相当不错的了解，至少为4.4%。也就是说，至少每23个人中就有一个人患有联觉。在那项研究中，我们研究了大约140种不同的联觉类型，但我们遗漏了一些非常关键的类型。因此，我们还独立地了解到，大约10%的人看到时间和数字或字母在空间中排列。
Now, that would add another sort of 10% to that figure that I gave earlier. We also know that at least one to two percent of the population have personalities for letters, numbers, days of the week, months of the year. So we would have to add that on as well. So, but it does really come down to what you think synesthesia is. If you think these numbers are getting quite high, they are, but you might want to question whether numbers mapped out in space, whether time mapped out in space, is a synesthesia. Because 10% of the population experiencing that makes us start to question, well, is this really synesthesia at all? But a very simple answer is at least 4% of the. the population. Now, that's an interesting prevalence because that feels small. 4.4% feels small,
现在，这会为我刚才给出的数字再增加大约10%。我们还知道，至少百分之一到二的人对字母、数字、星期几、月份有性格特征。所以我们也必须把这个加上。但这确实取决于你认为联觉是什么。如果你认为这些数字变得相当高，确实如此，但你可能会质疑空间中排列的数字、空间中排列的时间是否算是联觉。因为10%的人口体验到这一点，让我们开始质疑，这真的是联觉吗？但一个非常简单的答案是至少4%的人口。现在，这是一个有趣的患病率，因为这感觉很小。4.4%感觉很小，
but it's actually equivalent to the entire population of the United States in the world. So if you were to gather all synesthetes together, that would be 307 million synesthetes worldwide, which is, you know, somewhere approximating the USA population. So it's a rare condition, but not insignificant. And do you know, is it more common in men or women, or is it equally distributed? See, that's a very nice question again because it speaks to methodologies. So this early study of prevalence conducted by placing an advert in the newspaper and asking synesthetes to come forward gave the very, very strong impression that it was a female trait because I think something like eight times as many female synesthetes were found as males.
但它实际上相当于世界上美国总人口的数量。因此，如果你把所有的联觉者聚集在一起，那将是全球3.07亿联觉者，你知道的，大致相当于美国的人口。所以它是一种罕见的病症，但并非微不足道。你知道，它在男性中更常见还是在女性中更常见，还是分布均匀？看，这又是一个非常好的问题，因为它涉及方法论。因此，早期通过在报纸上登广告并要求联觉者主动站出来进行的患病率研究给人留下了非常非常深刻的印象，即它是一种女性特征，因为我发现女性联觉者的数量大约是男性的八倍。
So it put across the message that synesthesia was a female trait and that stayed with us for about a decade. However, it turns out that that was a trick of the methodology, a confound in the methodology, because in fact, we know from many other studies that women with unusual conditions are simply more likely to come forward. So what we actually have is a condition which is balanced across the senses. When you go out and screen people through a large population, you find the same number is the same number of male and female synesthetes. But when you ask them to come forward, the men hold back and the women reach out to scientists. I mentioned in the introduction that in the past couple of decades, scientists have begun using brain scans to understand what's happening
因此它传达了这样一个信息：联觉是一种女性特征，这个观点伴随了我们大约十年。然而，事实证明这只是方法论上的一个小把戏，是方法论中的一个混杂因素，因为事实上，我们从许多其他研究中了解到，患有不寻常病症的女性只是更有可能主动站出来。所以我们实际拥有的是一种在各个感官中平衡的病症。当你走出去通过庞大的人群筛查人们时，你会发现男性和女性联觉者的数量是相同的。但是当你要求他们主动站出来时，男性会退缩，而女性会向科学家伸出援手。我在引言中提到，在过去的几十年里，科学家们已经开始使用脑部扫描来了解发生了什么
in the brains of people with synesthesia. What have they found? Do the brains of people with synesthesia look different or function differently from the brains of people who don't have it? Yeah, I think brain imaging in synesthesia has been the most important scientific step forward in 200 years. I remember giving synesthesia lectures and synesthesia talks before the advent of these brain imaging findings. And I would spend the entire talk trying to persuade people that synesthesia was real. Now, somewhere around 2005, we got a sudden proliferation of imaging studies. And that was wonderful because now when I give synesthesia talks, the first thing I do is show the brain of a synestate in an fMRI image, for example, and the brain of a control, and they're so very different that I no longer have to struggle to persuade people on genuineness. So what do they show? These brain imaging studies show very nicely that the brains of synesthetes are different to those of people without synesthesia. They're different in their functionality. So in fMRI, we can see that. Color selective regions or regions close to colour areas in the visual cortex will light up
在联觉者的大脑中。他们发现了什么？联觉者的大脑看起来或功能上与没有联觉的人有什么不同吗？是的，我认为联觉中的脑成像技术是200年来最重要的科学飞跃。我记得在这些脑成像发现出现之前，我曾做过联觉讲座和联觉演讲。我花了整场演讲的时间试图说服人们联觉是真实的。现在，大约在2005年，我们突然迎来了成像研究的激增。这太棒了，因为现在当我做联觉演讲时，我做的第一件事就是展示一个联觉者在大脑fMRI图像中的大脑，例如，以及一个对照组的大脑，它们是如此不同，以至于我不再需要费力说服人们这是真实的。那么它们展示了什么？这些脑成像研究非常漂亮地表明，联觉者的大脑与没有联觉的人的大脑是不同的。它们的功能不同。因此，在fMRI中我们可以看到，
in response to reading black and white numbers for synesthetes, when obviously for controls those same regions would only light up if they were exposed to colour in the real world. And also some very nice data from our Dutch colleagues has shown that synesthetes have different structural qualities in their brain. So, differences in their white matter coherence in different parts of the brain. So greater white matter connectivity, near color selective regions, for example. Also, other interesting differences, differences in frontal areas, differences in parietal areas that might be linked to a greater binding.
对于联觉者来说，在阅读黑白数字时，视觉皮层中的颜色选择性区域或靠近颜色区域的区域会亮起，而显然对于对照组来说，只有在现实世界中接触到颜色时，这些相同的区域才会亮起。此外，我们荷兰同事的一些非常棒的数据表明，联觉者的大脑具有不同的结构品质。也就是说，大脑不同部分中白质相干性的差异。例如，在颜色选择性区域附近有更强的白质连接。此外，还有其他有趣的差异，额叶区域的差异，顶叶区域的差异，这些可能与更强大的绑定能力有关。
So binding is where we bring together different features of the world. So, for example, if I look at a green or apple, the greenness is in one part of the body. my brain. The shape of the apple is in another part of my brain. The binding region helps to bring those pieces of information together. And synestites have differences in parietal areas that deal with binding, almost as if they're overbinding features. They're not only binding the colours of apples to the shapes of apples. They're binding the colours of apples to letters and numbers and music and so on. So yeah, brain imaging has really revolutionised what you do.
因此，绑定是我们把世界的不同特征组合在一起的过程。例如，如果我看到一个绿色的苹果，绿色存在于身体的一个部位我的大脑中。苹果的形状在我大脑的另一个部位。绑定区域有助于将这些信息片段组合在一起。联觉者在处理绑定的顶叶区域存在差异，就好像他们过度绑定了特征一样。他们不仅将苹果的颜色绑定到苹果的形状上。他们将苹果的颜色绑定到字母、数字和音乐等等上面。所以是的，脑成像确实彻底革了你的研究的命。
So do researchers like you have any theories as to why synesthesia develops? And is it hereditary? Do you, is there a cause? Or you're just born with it? So on the question of inheritance, it does seem to be genetically endowed in some way, rather than, well, for a start, we do know, first of all, that it passes down through families. So a study back in 2005 with my colleague Jamie Ward showed that if you have synesthesia in the family, you're much more likely to have it sort of, you're more. like to have it popping up through generations than much more likely than you expect from chance alone. So it's passing through families. Now, of course, it could be learned. It could be parents teaching children. But we know that's not the case for several reasons. First of all, parents and children are likely to have very different kinds of synesthesia. So what's being passed on is a sort of predisposition for synesthesia. But you might have a parent with coloured letters whose son has tasty words. And so that suggests it's not being taught through the generations. And quite often for
那么像你这样的研究人员对于联觉是如何产生的有什么理论吗？它会遗传吗？你知道原因吗？还是天生就有的？关于遗传的问题，它在某种程度上似乎是基因赋予的，而不是……嗯，首先，我们确实知道，它会在家族中代代相传。2005年，我的同事杰米·沃德（Jamie Ward）做过一项研究，结果表明，如果你的家族中有联觉患者，你更有可能会表现出这种特质，它代代相传的几率远高于仅凭偶然性所期望的几率。所以它确实会在家族中遗传。当然，它也可能是后天学来的。可能是父母教给孩子的。但由于几个原因，我们知道事实并非如此。首先，父母和孩子往往拥有非常不同类型的联觉。因此，遗传下来的是一种对联觉的某种倾向。但你可能会发现，一个父母的字母是有颜色的，而他们的儿子听到的词语是有味道的。这表明它并不是通过代际传递教授出来的。而且通常由于这个原因
that reason, families are not aware that they have so much synesthesia going on. So if I'm a person with coloured letters, why would I suddenly ask my child, what's the taste of Tuesday? It wouldn't happen. So quite often you get these families with multiple variants appearing. And then there are more direct genetics findings. So I mentioned earlier, Julian Asher did some pioneering research with Simon Baron Cohen on the genetics. More recently, the Max Planck Institute in Nymegan has got a fantastic genetics project going on, screening hundreds and hundreds and hundreds, hopefully thousands and thousands of synesthetes. And finding hotspots on chromosomes that are suggestive of synesthesia, it's unfortunately, it's not a clean picture. Sometimes in the genetics,
家族往往并不知道他们身上存在这么多的联觉现象。所以，如果我是一个看到字母有颜色的人，我为什么会突然问我的孩子“星期二是什么味道的”？这不会发生。因此，你经常会发现这些家族中出现了多种不同的联觉变体。然后还有更直接的基因发现。所以我刚才提到过，朱利安·阿舍（Julian Asher）曾与西蒙·巴伦-科恩（Simon Baron Cohen）在基因研究方面进行过开创性的研究。最近，位于奈梅亨的马克斯·普朗克研究所正在进行一项非常棒的基因项目，他们对成百上千甚至数千名联觉者进行了筛查。并在染色体上找到了暗示联觉的热点区域。不幸的是，这并不是一幅清晰的画面。有时在基因研究中
it's quite easy to point to genes. What we're finding is that different families seem to have, have different families and different variants of synesthesia seem to have different genetic profiles. So it hasn't been a very easy task or a very clean picture, but we have got these areas on the genome that are hotspots if you like for certain kinds of synesthesia in certain families. If a person with synesthesia experiences a trauma, such as a blow to the head or even a very high fever. Is that something that could make the synesthesia disappear? And conversely, if you didn't have it, but then you experienced a blow to the head, could it triggers synesthesia? Or is that just an off-the-wall question? Actually, I think both those things
指出特定基因是相当容易的。我们发现的是，不同的家族似乎拥有不同的联觉变体，并且表现出不同的基因特征。因此，这并不是一项轻松的任务，也不是一幅清晰的画面，但我们的确在基因组上找到了这些区域，如果你愿意的话，它们就是某些家族中特定联觉类型的热点区域。如果一个患有联觉的人经历了创伤，例如头部受到重击，甚至是极高的发烧，这种情况会使联觉消失吗？反过来，如果你本来没有联觉，但后来头部受到了重击，这能引发联觉吗？还是这只是一个异想天开的问题？事实上，我认为这两种情况
are true. There are rare cases of acquired synesthesia after trauma. There are also cases of synesthesia disappearing under certain circumstances. Now, it's not very well studied because obviously we can't replicate this very one in the lab and nor would we want to because I wouldn't be the person to take away a synesthesia. But there are cases, there's anecdotal reports, there's some really reliable anecdotal reports. So there is a case of a very prominent synestead who has very sadly experienced the Japanese earthquake and felt for some time afterwards that his synesthesia was deadened. And that was quite a troubling thing for him to deal with. Luckily, it's come back. I've had also synesthetes contacting me, asking me about medication. They're
都是真的。创伤后获得性联觉的罕见病例是存在的。在某些情况下，联觉也会消失。现在，这方面的研究还不是很充分，因为显然我们无法在实验室里完美地复制这种情况，我们也不想这么做，因为我可不想成为剥夺别人联觉的人。但确实有这样的案例，有一些轶事报告，还有一些非常可靠的轶事报告。所以有一个非常著名的联觉者的案例，他非常不幸地经历了日本大地震，并在之后的很长一段时间里觉得他的联觉变得迟钝了。这对他来说是一件很棘手的事情。幸运的是，它又恢复了。也有联觉者联系我，向我询问关于药物的事情。他们
on a medication and suddenly the synesthesia is attenuated. When we give large surveys to synesthetes and ask them for self-reports, sometimes reports of caffeine making differences, but it's very hard for us to pin this down in the lab. So quite often you'll find these reports in case study journals, which are really useful. So one thing that you've written about that I found surprising was that people are not always reliable reporters of whether they have synesthesia. Some people with it don't realize they have it. Some non-synesthetes will say that they do. Why is that? And how do you test to determine whether someone actually has synesthesia.
正在服用某种药物，然后联觉突然减弱了。当我们对联觉者进行大规模调查并要求他们进行自我报告时，有时会听到咖啡因会带来差异的报告，但我们在实验室里很难准确证实这一点。因此，你经常会在个案研究期刊中发现这些报告，它们真的非常有用。你写过的一篇文章中让我感到惊讶的一点是，人们对于自己是否拥有联觉的报告并不总是可靠的。有些拥有联觉的人并没有意识到自己有，而有些没有联觉的人却说自己有。这是为什么呢？你如何通过测试来确定一个人是否真的患有联觉？
So the first time I came across this, I was really surprised by quite how inaccurate self-report is in synesthesia. Let me answer this by telling you how we verify synesthesia first of all. So we have a very nice test for synesthesia that seems robust and has been used since 1989, early 90s. Again, this was a very nice test that Simon Baron Cohen was able to pioneer. So we test synesthetes by looking for a trait called consistency over time. So what we do is we ask synesthetes to tell us their associations.
所以，我第一次遇到这种情况时，对联觉中自我报告的不准确程度感到非常震惊。请允许我先通过告诉你我们如何验证联觉来回答这个问题。我们有一个关于联觉的非常好的测试，它似乎很稳健，自1989年或90年代初以来一直被使用。同样，这是西蒙·巴伦-科恩能够开创的一项非常好的测试。因此，我们通过寻找一种名为“随时间保持一致性”的特征来测试联觉者。我们所做的是要求联觉者告诉我们他们的联想。
And in fact, we do this in more sophisticated ways. So for example, we have tests that show the letters and numbers in a random order. Every time a grapheme appears, the synestites required to choose the specific synesthetic colour from a really fine-grained colour palette that has like 16 million colours. So an A will appear, the synestite will choose their exact shade of red. A seven will appear, the synestite will choose their exact shade of green and so on. And once they get to the end of the test, we surprise synesthetes and we repeat it. So they do the whole thing over and over again.
事实上，我们用更复杂的方法来做到这一点。例如，我们有这样的测试，字母和数字以随机顺序出现。每当一个字素出现时，联觉者需要从一个非常细腻的调色板（包含大约1600万种颜色）中选择特定的联觉颜色。因此，当字母A出现时，联觉者会选择他们确切的红色色调；数字7出现时，联觉者会选择他们确切的绿色色调，以此类推。当他们完成测试的最后一步时，我们会给联觉者一个惊喜并重复测试。所以他们会一遍又一遍地做完整的事情。
And they can do this anything from twice to maybe three times. And what we have at the end is each letter and number with the colours given to it over time by the same synestite. And then we can use a technique that allows us to look at colour distance. So when I ask you for the colour of A, the first time, and the second time, I plot those colours in space and I say, how close are they in space? Now, if you are consistent, those colours will be very close in colour space. You'll have said the same shade of red twice. If you ask a control, they'll be inventing it, making it up very inconsistent, very large distances in colour space. So we can quantify the consistency of a synestite in terms of, you know, distances in color space.
他们可以这样做两到三次。最后得到的结果是，同一个联觉者在不同时间赋予每个字母和数字的颜色。然后，我们可以使用一种技术来观察颜色距离。因此，当我第一次和第二次问你A的颜色时，我把这些颜色绘制在空间中，并问：它们在空间中有多接近？现在，如果你保持一致，这些颜色在色彩空间中会非常接近。你会说出两次相同的红色色调。如果你问一个对照组的受试者，他们会凭空捏造，非常不一致，在色彩空间中的距离非常大。因此，我们可以根据色彩空间中的距离来量化联觉者的CONSISTENCY（一致性）。
And this shows us that synesthetes are very, very, very, very consistent. You're not going to fool them. If you say what color is seven, they're always going to tell you exactly the same shade of, I don't know, subtle, lime, green. They're going to be spot on. And controls are going to be inconsistent. And so we have a threshold of consistency. Synesthetes have to be above the threshold in order to be validated as a synestite. So when we run these tests, we usually start by saying,
这向我们表明，联觉者的表现非常、非常、非常、非常一致。你是无法愚弄他们的。如果你问他们数字7是什么颜色的，他们总是会告诉你完全相同的某种……我不知道，微妙的青柠绿。他们会说得极为准确。而对照组的受试者则会不一致。因此，我们设定了一个一致性阈值。联觉者必须高于这个阈值才能被验证为真正的联觉者。因此，当我们进行这些测试时，我们通常首先会问：
first of all, this is synesthesia, have you got synesthesia? And you would think that everybody who says yes goes on to be consistent and everybody who says no goes on to be inconsistent. But actually what we find is that for every true consistent synestate who says they have synesthesia, there are five non-sinistites saying they have synesthesia. And the reasons are actually not too surprising. There's a tiny bit of social desirability. It's quite nice. to say you have something interesting. But actually, there are a lot of artists who say they have synesthesia because what they have is a really fine-grained appreciation for colour. And that's quite easy to confuse. So lots of the non-cinesthetes, reporting synesthesia are artists. Some of them
首先，这就是联觉，你有联觉吗？你可能会认为，所有回答“是”的人接下来都会表现出一致性，而所有回答“否”的人则会表现出不一致。但实际上我们发现，对于每一个说自己有联觉的真正一致的联觉者来说，都有五个没有联觉的人说自己有联觉。原因其实并不太令人意外。其中有一点点社会赞许性的因素。说自己有一些有趣的东西是挺不错的。但实际上，有很多艺术家说自己有联觉，因为他们拥有的是对颜色非常细腻的欣赏能力。而这很容易被混淆。因此，许多声称自己有联觉的非联觉者其实是艺术家。他们中的一些人
are just sort of, some of them are just mistaken. Some of them are just not concentrating. But all in all, if I ever now review papers on synesthesia where there's no consistency test, it's dead in the water because you don't know you have synesthesia. So you were talking about artists and creative types. Is it more likely that a person who is creative and is an artist would have synesthesia? Is there actually some association? Sure, yes, there seems to be. So first of all, if you look within creative disciplines, you're more likely to find synesthetes.
只是……有些只是搞错了。有些只是不够专注。但总而言之，如果我现在审阅关于联觉且没有包含一致性测试的论文，那它就毫无价值了，因为你并不知道自己是否有联觉。所以你刚才在谈论艺术家和具有创造力的人。富有创造力且身为艺术家的人更有可能拥有联觉吗？这两者之间真的有什么关联吗？当然，是的，似乎确实有。首先，如果你在创意学科内部寻找，你更有可能找到联觉者。
Now, that makes it difficult because artists are more likely to inaccurately say they have synesthesia, but there's still more synesthesia among artistic people. So you have to really use these careful tests. But yes, you find synesthet's more likely to go into artistic professions and those professions are tied to their synesthesia. So more musicians with coloured music synesthesia, for example. We can also find evidence of higher creativity with lab tests. So for example, a test of creativity that's quite well-known.
现在，这带来了一些困难，因为艺术家更有可能不准确地宣称自己有联觉，但艺术人群中确实仍然存在更多的联觉现象。因此，你必须真正使用这些仔细的测试。不过是的，你会发现联觉者更有可能从事艺术职业，并且这些职业与他们的联觉紧密相连。例如，拥有彩色音乐联觉的音乐家就更多。我们还可以在实验室测试中找到更高创造力的证据。例如，一个广为人知的创造力测试是
known is the remote associates test. And in that test, you're given three words such as, you're given three words and you have to provide the fourth word that links them all. And I have to think carefully about this so I don't reveal the linking word, but an example might be boot, yeah, this is tough, boot, ground, summer. Now, those three words are linked by one other word, and that other word is camp. So boot camp, summer camp, campground. And this is a test of creativity, and synestities performed very well in this test. We also have evidence that this creativity is starting quite early. So we have recently finished a large ERC funded project. So European Research Council funded us to look at
远距离联想测试。在这个测试中，你会得到三个词，例如，你得到三个词，然后你必须提供将它们全部连接起来的第四个词。我必须仔细考虑这一点，以免泄露连接词，但一个例子可能是“boot”（靴子），是的，这很难，“boot”（靴子）、“ground”（地面）、“summer”（夏天）。现在，这三个词由另一个词连接，而那个词是“camp”（营地）。所以是：boot camp（新兵训练营）、summer camp（夏令营）、campground（营地）。这是一个创造力的测试，联觉者在这个测试中表现得非常好。我们还有证据表明这种创造力开始得很早。因此，我们最近完成了一个由欧洲研究委员会（ERC）资助的大型项目。欧洲研究委员会资助我们研究
synesthesia in children for five years. And we can even see those creativity traits emerging early in children. So when we find children with synesthesia from the general population, so we're not relying on people to come forward. We've screened thousands of children. We've found the synesthetes among them and we look at their personality and the children don't really realize they're special. The parents don't know that their children have synesthesia, but everybody concurs that these synesthetes are higher in the trait of openness to experiences, which is linked to intellectual curiosity but also creativity. So children themselves feel that they're more creative in their personalities. Their parents feel they have more creative personalities. And we can see this from really
儿童的联觉，为期五年。我们甚至可以看到这些创造力特质在儿童身上很早就开始显现。因此，当我们从普通人群中找到患有联觉的儿童时——也就是说我们不依赖人们主动来找我们，我们已经筛查了数千名儿童，并在其中找到了联觉者——我们观察他们的性格，这些儿童其实并没有意识到自己很特殊。家长也不知道他们的孩子患有联觉，但大家都一致认为，这些联觉者在“开放性体验”这一特质上得分更高，这与求知欲以及创造力息息相关。因此，孩子们自己觉得他们的性格更有创造力。他们的家长也觉得他们更有创造力。我们可以从真的
a young age, from the age of around. I think the children we tested were between six and ten. And we can see these effects emerging, you know, by, if not by six, then by, you know, seven or eight. So yes, creative population. So you've done research that's found that even though most people do not have synesthesia, they do have cross-sensory experiences or associations, for example, associating higher-pitched tones with brighter colors. Can you tell us about that research and how it relates to synesthesia? Sure. This is always an area of research that can really play with my head because we look at many different sensory domains and we look at how they cross-over in many different ways. So I'm going to think carefully. So the one that you just described is actually
很小的年龄就看到这一点，大约从……我认为我们测试的儿童年龄在六岁到十岁之间。我们可以看到这些效应开始显现，如果不是在六岁时，那么也是在七、八岁时。所以，是的，创意人群。因此，你做过的一项研究发现，尽管大多数人没有联觉，但他们确实有跨感官体验或联想，例如将较高音调的音符与更明亮的颜色联系起来。你能给我们讲讲那项研究以及它与联觉的关系吗？当然。这始终是一个能真正让我脑洞大开的研究领域，因为我们研究了许多不同的感官领域，并研究了它们如何在许多不同的方式中交叉。所以我要仔细思考一下。那么你刚才描述的那种其实是
a great finding by, among other people, my colleague Jamie Ward. He has shown that people systematically associate the pitch of music with colours in several ways. So, for example, higher pitch. So imagine a test where I play you sounds and I ask you to choose colours and you feel like you're randomly picking because I play you a high pitch sound, a low pitch sound, a, you know, a stringed instrument, a piano. and I just ask you to pick colours and you kind of, you're willing to do this task, although you suspend disbelief because you think you're going to be random.
我的同事杰米·沃德（Jamie Ward）等人的一个重大发现。他已经证明，人们系统地以几种方式将音乐的音调与颜色联系起来。例如，更高的音调。想象这样一个测试，我为你播放声音并要求你选择颜色，你觉得你是在随机挑选，因为我为你播放了一个高音、一个低音、一个弦乐器、一个钢琴的声音，然后我只是要求你挑选颜色，你有点……你愿意完成这个任务，尽管你暂时抛开了怀疑，因为你认为你的选择会是随机的。
And actually, people are very, very consistent. Higher pitch sound maps to more luminant colours. So imagine a piano, imagine I'm on a piano and I'm tinkling on the high notes and I'm crashing on the low notes and I say to you which one of those is pale yellow. And you are much more likely to say that the pale yellow is the higher pitch note. Okay, and maybe deep dark purple is the low pitch note. So there's that, there's that association. But there are many, many, many of these associations.
而实际上，人们表现得非常、非常一致。更高音调的声音会映射到更亮（luminant）的颜色上。想象一架钢琴，想象我在弹钢琴，在弹高音时叮咚作响，在弹低音时重重按下，我对你说哪个是淡黄色。你更有可能会说淡黄色是那个音调更高的音符。好吧，也许深沉的暗紫色是那个音调较低的音符。所以，存在着这种关联。但是有非常、非常、非常多的这种关联。
So we have shown that if you give people an identical sweetie, an identical candy, and it either has a rough surface or a smooth surface, they will think that the candy is more sour with the rough surface, even though it has the identical ingredients. And here's something quite fun. We have recently been looking at the same phenomenon. in dogs. So research in collaboration with my colleague David Reby and our student Anna Koshanovska, who's leading this research, we have taken domestic dogs into the lab and we show them different
因此我们已经证明，如果你给人们一块完全相同的糖果，一块糖果表面粗糙，另一块糖果表面光滑，即使它们的成分完全相同，他们也会觉得表面粗糙的那块糖果更酸。这里有一个相当有趣的事情。我们最近一直在研究相同的现象在狗身上是否也存在。通过与我的同事大卫·雷比（David Reby）以及正在领导这项研究的学生安娜·科沙诺夫斯卡（Anna Koshanovska）合作，我们将家养犬带到实验室中，并向它们展示了不同的
objects. So they're either objects of a different size or they're elevated differently in space and we play sounds and we train the dogs in advance to go to the object that's making a sound. and what we find is that they're much more likely to target the small object when the sound is high-pitched and the large object when the sound is low-pitched. And similarly, when the sound is high-pitched, they look up to an object up in space, and when the sound is low-pitch, they look down to an object on the ground. So this shows associations between on the one-hand sound and on the other hand the visual property of size or the visual property of elevation in space.
物体。这些物体要么大小不同，要么在空间中的高度不同，我们播放声音，并预先训练狗去寻找发出声音的物体。我们发现，当声音音调较高时，它们更有可能将目标对准小型物体；而当声音音调较低时，则更有可能对准大型物体。同样，当声音音调较高时，它们会抬头看向空间上方的物体；而当声音音调较低时，它们则会低头看向地上的物体。这表明，一方面声音与另一方面视觉属性的大小或空间高度之间存在着关联。
And that's some really exciting work that's been really fun to conduct. Wow, that's amazing. So let me change gears a little bit, because in addition to synesthesia, you study a variety of other brain and sensory differences. For example, as I said earlier, misophonia, which is an extreme aversion to specific sounds, and Afantasia, which is the inability to picture things in your mind's eye. These seem like really disparate concepts, but how do they tie together?
这是一项非常令人兴奋的工作，做起来也非常有趣。哇，太神奇了！那么让我稍微转换一下话题，因为除了联觉之外，你还研究了各种其他的大脑和感官差异。例如，正如我刚才所说，恐音症（对特定声音极度厌恶），以及心象缺失症（无法在脑海中想象出事物的影像）。这些听起来是非常截然不同的概念，但它们是如何联系在一起的呢？
That's such a good question because... Or do they? Yeah, that's a really good question because I found myself working in synesthesia for a couple of decades and then being introduced to other sensory differences, finding them fascinating, berating myself for not having focus for effectively coming away from synesthesia, finding out over time that these different conditions are tied by kind of invisible thread. So all of them are sensory differences and they all share certain traits in common. For example, in terms of well-being, so we find that people with these sensory differences,
这是一个非常好的问题，因为……或者说它们真的有联系吗？是的，这是一个非常好的问题，因为我发现自己研究联觉已经有几十年了，后来又接触到了其他的感官差异，发现它们非常迷人，并为自己没有专注于联觉、实际上从联觉研究中抽身出来而感到自责，但随着时间的推移，我发现这些不同的病症被某种无形的线索紧密相连。因为它们全都是感官差异，并且它们都具有某些共同的特征。例如，在福祉方面，我们发现患有这些感官差异的人，
even synesthesia that sometimes considered a gift, can have impairments in their well-being, can have problems in their well-being. So for example, in synesthesia, we found that people, with synesthesia, with verified synesthesia, are significantly more likely to experience anxiety disorder than other people. We were really surprised about this. We weren't looking at particularly troubling variants. We were looking at coloured letters and numbers, higher rates of anxiety disorder. We've just finished a similar study in child synesthetes, and 30% of our child synesthetes under 10 qualify for sort of the category of anxiety disorder, which is really high,
甚至是被有时被认为是一种天赋的联觉，也会对他们的福祉造成损害，可能会在福祉方面产生问题。例如，在联觉方面，我们发现患有联觉的人，即经过验证的联觉者，比其他人显著更有可能经历焦虑症。我们对此感到非常惊讶。我们当时并没有寻找特别令人困扰的变体。我们研究的是有颜色的字母和数字，却发现焦虑症的发病率更高。我们刚刚在儿童联觉者中完成了一项类似的研究，在我们10岁以下的儿童联觉者中，有30%符合某种焦虑症的类别，这个比例真的非常高。
usually in children it's around in our controls we've found it at around less than 10 synesthetes at 30% and similarly in these other disciplines in these other similarly in these other sensory differences so misophonia itself is it's almost defined by by difficulties in well-being so misophonia can give rise to great anxiety as well as so misophonia is an extreme hatred of certain sounds and those sounds tend to be bodily sounds like coughing or chewing or crunching or swallowing. And it can really give rise to these incredible differences in well-being, anxiety, rage, uncontrollable feelings, really, that we know are also linked to brain structure. And what we found in children as young as 10 is that children that we've been able to recognise as having misophonia are showing serious
通常在儿童中，大约在我们的对照组中，我们发现10岁以下的联觉者比例约为30%，在其他这些学科、其他这些类似的感官差异中也是如此，所以恐音症本身几乎就是由幸福感困难所定义的，因此恐音症会导致极大的焦虑，以及——恐音症是对某些声音的极端厌恶，这些声音往往是身体的声音，比如咳嗽、咀嚼、咯吱声或吞咽。它确实会带来这种令人难以置信的幸福感差异、焦虑、愤怒、真正无法控制的情绪，我们知道这也与大脑结构有关。我们在年仅10岁的儿童身上发现的是，我们能够识别出患有恐音症的儿童正在表现出严重的
differences in their well-being, again, elevated anxiety, as you might expect, but also poorer quality of life, poorer satisfaction in life. And then there's also the link with autistic-like traits. So the more we look at these sensory differences, the more we see parallels with and overlaps with autism. Now, it's not the case that having synesthesia means you're autistic, but it does mean that you're elevated on tests of autism in certain areas. So in misophonia, for example, you're significantly more likely to be diagnosed or recognized as having autism than the average person. In synesthesia, you're elevated on the traits of attention to detail. In synesthesia, you're elevated on the autistic trait of attention to detail.
幸福感差异，再次表现为如你所料的焦虑加剧，但也伴随着较低的生活质量和较低的生活满意度。此外，它还与自闭症样特质有关。因此，我们对这些感官差异的研究越多，我们就越能看到它与自闭症的相似之处和重叠之处。现在，这并不是说拥有联觉就意味着你是自闭症患者，但它确实意味着你在某些领域的自闭症测试中得分更高。例如，在恐音症中，你被诊断或识别为患有自闭症的可能性明显高于普通人。在联觉中，你在对细节的关注这一特质上得分较高。在联觉中，你在对细节关注的自闭症特质上得分较高。
And in misophonia, no, and in Afantasia, you're elevated in the autistic traits of social difficulties and imagination. And so, yes, there's this overlap of autistic traits. There's this overlapping well-being, poor well-being. So the more I look at many different sensory conditions, the more I'm convinced that they all really fit together in a kind of coherent whole. Here's one I'll throw at you. So we had a guest a few months back, did an episode on face blindness. And one of the people is someone I know who has been diagnosed with face blindness.
而在恐音症中，不，在心盲症中，你在社交困难和想象力这两项自闭症特质上得分较高。所以，是的，自闭症特质存在这种重叠。幸福感存在这种重叠，即较低的幸福感。因此，我对许多不同的感官状况研究得越多，我就越确信它们实际上都以一种连贯的整体契合在一起。这里有一个问题抛给你。几个月前我们有一位嘉宾，做了一期关于面孔失认症的节目。其中一个人是我认识的一个被诊断为面孔失认症的人。
And she recently also learned that she has Afantasia. Have you looked at those connections? We have. We have and we are, actually. So I think in self-report, people with A Fantasia report being poorer at faces, on average. And a very nice study we're conducting here at Sussex, led by my PhD student Carla Dance, and in collaboration with my colleague Graham Holt, who's a witness recognition, a face recognition expert, we've been able to give identicates to people with Afantasia.
她最近还得知自己患有心盲症。你们研究过这些联系吗？我们研究过。我们确实研究过，而且正在研究。因此，我认为在自我报告中，心盲症患者平均报告的面部识别能力较差。我们在萨塞克斯大学正在进行一项非常出色的研究，由我的博士生卡拉·丹斯领导，并与我的同事格雷厄姆·霍尔特合作——他是一位证人识别和面部识别专家——我们已经能够向心盲症患者提供面部特征复合图。
And we show them a face and then we ask them to reconstruct the face using these identities and then we give the reconstructed face to a group of controls and ask them, how similar is this reconstructed face with the original? And we do that once for our people with Afantasia and once for controls. And we're in the middle of doing that study right now. and we can see trends in the direction that we'd expect, but we need to finish that study to find out exactly whether it's significant, but it does look at the moment as if it's trending in the direction of what we would expect,
我们向他们展示一张脸，然后要求他们使用这些面部特征复合图来重建这张脸，接着我们将重建的面包展示给一组对照组，并问他们：“这张重建的脸与原作有多相似？”我们对心盲症患者做一次，对对照组也做一次。我们目前正在进行这项研究，我们可以看到符合我们预期的趋势，但我们需要完成这项研究，才能确切知道它是否具有统计学意义，不过目前看来，它的确朝着我们所预期的方向发展，
which is poorer face recall for people with Afantasia. Although I need to add something. This is only a typical of the average Afantasic. So what we actually find is a real spread, and it's quite interesting because I have Afantasia myself. but I'm almost a super recogniser. So when I perform tests of face recognition, I'm almost good enough to work for the police.
也就是心盲症患者的面部回忆能力较差。尽管我需要补充一点。这只是典型心盲症患者的一个平均情况。实际上我们发现的是一个相当广泛的分布，这非常有趣，因为我自己就有心盲症，但我几乎是一个超级面孔识别者。因此，当我进行面部识别测试时，我的表现几乎好到可以为警方工作了。
How am I doing that? How am I doing that? I have no mental imagery, but I'm just able to pick out a face in the crowd very well. So there you go. It's a spread, but the average person is less good than controls. So I'm just wondering if particularly Missifonia and Afantasia are debilitating to the people who have,
我是怎么做到的？我是怎么做到的？我没有心理意象，但我就是能够在人群中很好地认出一张脸。所以你看。这是一个分布，但普通人的表现不如对照组。我只是在想，尤其是恐音症和心盲症，是否会给患有这些综合征的人带来严重影响，是否有可能帮助人们学会减弱对声音的厌恶，或者教导人们如何在脑海中看到事物？
have these syndromes and is it possible to help someone learn to diminish, say, an aversion to sounds or to teach people how to see things in their mind's eye? Yeah, definitely. And I think that is definitely happening a lot more for misophonia. So misophonia is defined as a kind of almost chronic condition. And misophonia is also really a topic of focus for clinicians. A lot of clinicians are trying to find out exactly how we can fix this problem. There are some long-term clinical treatment options.
是的，绝对可以。我认为对于恐音症来说，这方面的情况肯定正在增加。因此，恐音症被定义为一种几乎是慢性的状况。恐音症也是临床医生关注的一个真正的话题。许多临床医生正试图找出我们如何才能解决这个问题的确切方法。有一些长期的临床治疗选择。
Cognitive behavioural therapy has been tried. A tinnitus retraining therapy, a counter-conditioning therapy. They aim to reconceptualise the individual's relationship with sound. Or they repair unpleasant sounds with more pleasant responses. some approaches combine therapy with gentle exposure. It's still quite a young science. It's still quite a young science. There isn't really an outstanding treatment that's emerging above all others.
人们已经尝试过认知行为疗法。耳鸣习服疗法、反条件反射疗法。它们旨在重新构建个体与声音的关系。或者用更愉悦的反应来修复令人不快的声音。一些方法将疗法与温和的暴露相结合。这仍然是一门相当年轻的科学。这仍然是一门相当年轻的科学。目前并没有真正涌现出一种超越所有其他治疗方法的卓越疗法。
We're just trying. Clinicians are just trying different options at the moment. Some of them are effective but not across the board. A fantasia is an interesting one. people aren't really trying to improve imagery at the moment in Afantasics. I mean, I know personally I found out I had Afantasia around 10 years ago. I was having an interesting chat with a colleague about synestites, and I said to him, these synestites are reporting that they can see pictures in their mind's eyes.
我们只是在尝试。临床医生目前正在尝试不同的选择。其中一些有效，但并非全面有效。心盲症则是一个有趣的例子，目前人们并没有真正在心盲症患者身上尝试改善意象。我的意思是，就我个人而言，大约10年前我发现自己患有心盲症。当时我和一位同事在愉快地聊着关于联觉者的事，我对他说，这些联觉者报告说他们能在脑海中看到图片。
So if I say pig, they literally see an image of a pig. And I was speaking to my colleague Bob Logi, who said, well, that's what everybody does, isn't it? And I said, no, you don't understand. They see a picture in their mind. He said, yeah, that's what everybody does. So from that moment, 10 years ago, I have tried, personally speaking, I've tried to construct images. I don't, I haven't had a great deal of success, to be honest. Although that's an N of 1, so who knows, so maybe we might try it.
所以如果我说了“猪”，他们字面意义上就会看到一头猪的图像。我和我的同事鲍勃·洛吉交谈过，他说：“哦，每个人都这样，不是吗？”我说：“不，你不明白。他们在脑海里看到了一张图片。”他说：“对，每个人都这样。”所以从10年前的那个时刻起，就我个人而言，我一直试图构建图像。说实话，我并没有取得多大的成功。尽管这是一个N=1的个案，所以谁知道呢，也许我们还是会尝试一下。
But really, the difference between Afantasia and Misophonia is that people with Afantasia are getting on fine. They're just getting on fine with their life. They really have no idea. They're different. They understand visual imagery as a metaphor. You know, they, it's really nice. not a big deal in my life. I'm not very good at interior decorating. I find that quite hard. What's this sofa going to look like against that wall? Really, apart from that, it's fine.
但实际上，心盲症和恐音症的区别在于，心盲症患者的生活过得很好。他们只是生活得很顺利。他们真的不知道自己有什么不同。他们把视觉意象理解为一种隐喻。你知道，他们，这真的很美好。这在我生活中不是什么大问题。我不擅长室内装饰。我发现这挺难的。这个沙发靠着那堵墙会是什么样子？真的，除此之外，一切都很好。
Well, this has been just amazingly interesting, Dr. Simna. I've really enjoyed talking to you. I appreciate your taking the time. Thank you. Thanks so much. It's been a pleasure. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www. speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org.
好吧，西姆纳博士，这真的非常有趣。我真的很享受与您的交谈。我很感激您抽出时间。谢谢。非常感谢。这是一种荣幸。谢谢。您可以在 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学访谈》以前的节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。也就是 Speaking of Psychology（全部连写）@ APA.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学访谈》由莉·威纳曼制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪汉。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。